Good morning from South Africa guys,
We're going to go to the beautiful Orange River.
It's a 7 hour drive.
And we're going to do some fishing.
We're going to do some hunting.
We're going to do men's stuff,
not that women can't do it, but
it's going to be a men's trip.
Jaques is going to go with us as well.
We're going to get Danie there but first
we need to get everything here in there.
In South Africa we call it a bakkie.
You guys call it a truck.
But let's get to it.
Bye.
Let's go!
So there are a lot of road stops here in
South Africa and now we just sit and wait.
But me and Jaques, we've got some Pannekoek.
In South Africa, we call this Pannekoek,
and this is amazing.
We've got some pancakes
here, some food for the road.
And then some of these meatballs.
And let me tell you this is the best thing you
can buy if you're in South Africa on the road.
We finally arrived here at Tzamenkomst.
Me and Jaques, we are here.
But Danie, our friend, he already beat us to it.
And as you can see, we are
busy with the tackle here.
Because it's very windy.
Look at the beautiful river.
So we're not going to fish today - might
be a little bit too late with this wind.
Tomorrow we're definitely going to give it a shot.
Alright guys, it is late so I'm going to sleep.
Tomorrow we're going to go and do some fishing.
It's a beautiful unit that they
have here at Tzamenkomst.
I'm going to leave all the details for
you guys in the video description if you want to
come here, have a sleepover and catch some fish,
which we will do in the morning.
So I'll see you in the morning.
Good morning guys.
What a beautiful morning it
is here at the Orange River.
I mean, just look at it.
It's a bit windy but it's still okay.
I got my coffee and I'm going to do
some bible studying with the guys.
There they are, so we'll see
you guys a little bit later.
Wow, we just had an amazing
time just in God's Word.
And we prayed together and you know it feels
so good starting the day like this with God.
But, there's a small gym here and because this is
a men's getaway - a men's weekend - we're going
to work out together as well.
So, let's get to it.
I'm ready to work out but I forgot my shoes.
Jaques says he's got some shoes
for me as well, thank you.
Danie you got some shoes as well?
We came prepared.
You guys prepared?
Yeah and I took care of my bare feet.
Man these units look good.
So who sleeps in this one?
That's me.
Wow, it's quite nice huh?
Yeah.
And then if you just walk out, you have the river.
So, you guys ready to work out?
Ready.
Wow, this is a nice spot, huh.
Look at this.
Oh nice, looks like everything we need, huh?
This is so beautiful.
I think we should just come and
live here, just come and stay here.
I'm older, I'm getting gray
now, so be gentle Jaques.
Oh I'm getting old.
But not cold.
Wouldn't say it a lot but Jaques, these
guns, he doesn't have a permit for those.
In trouble, yeah.
Ah, well done.
Let me see those guns.
Definitely got big calves, look at those.
Yo, monsters.
You've got the best, see
a little bit, no can't see it put them down, put
them down, let me see, wait wait wait wait, yes.
But I've got the best ones -
look at these monsters - we
can't almost see them. There's no calves there.
Yeah, nothing but those.... those are the calves
God gave me so I'm
content.
We're busy working out.
Jaques is doing his last set over there.
He's done but while we were working
out we saw some fish jump here.
And they're going crazy.
We're going to quickly go.
We're going to do a few casts and
see if we can get a fish or two.
Ready, Jaques?
We've got the rods... we've got everything.
The wind is still not in our
favor but yeah, we're ready to go.
This is quite nice because it's not easy to get
to the location, and that's part of the fun.
I'm not sure if we can go through this area -
if it's shallow enough - but let's have a look.
Okay, we made it but it's a little bit deep.
I think we should move a little bit further on.
Wow it's beautiful here.
I think this is the spot.
Let's see what we can catch.
My granddad had a farm and on the farm
we fished a lot on the Orange River.
So this is special.
So to start this off, I'm going to
fish the way my granddad fished.
Now the fish we're going to catch here,
they are indigenous to South Africa.
The amazing Yellowfish.
Now these fish, man, they are amazing.
When they bite, they take off like a Ferrari.
And so it's one of the the best fish
that you can catch here in South Africa.
And that's what I'm going to show you today.
There are two types - small mouth and large mouth.
Now the large mouths are more rare,
but they're more hunters and they've got big
mouths but if you do catch them they can go
over 10 kilos so that's what we hope to catch.
So let me show you quickly here what I've done.
So the sinker - it's going to be very easy.
Just put it in like that.
You bring it around.
You bring it in.
And done.
Then you do the
exact same thing with the two hooks and then
I'm going to try to catch the Yellowfish and
the method we use here in South Africa.
I'm going to take some dough - some cake
flour - and I'm going to add some special - unique
- well, let me just show you what I'm going to do.
But first, let me add the hooks.
So these are the size hooks that you want to use.
It's not big, just the right size for these fish.
Let me just hold this on here... don't do this
at home ... and you just go
around and pull it through.
There you go.
That's the one.
I'm going to add another one here
.... there we go around and through.
There we go - quick and easy.
Now, we need to make the dough.
So I got some cake flour here
and all I'm going to do is...
I'm going to use the water of the river
and I'm just going to make a dough.
You can see Danie is already there fishing.
And he's using a lure so you can catch
these fish with lures.
Fly fishing or <Afrikaans>
as we call it in South Africa.
Alright, so I added the water.
Now you got to just do the
mixture and make some nice dough.
We hope that Danie is going
to catch a fish over here.
Danie, any bites?
Little nibbles, little nibbles.
So I brought some secret stuff with me and we
call them certain dips here in South Africa.
It's the same method that people
use to catch carp here as well.
But let me show you.
And this is a dip that we're going to use.
It's smells interesting.
Some of it smells like garlic,
some of it smells like cinnamon, you get
different types but these fish love it.
And here on the Orange River they like cinnamon.
So I've got a cinnamon one and I've got a few
other things as well and I'm going
to show you how you put this on the
hook with these dips to present the bait
and then see if we can catch something.
I think we are close.
I think this is it.
This is it.
I'm just going to wash
my hands quickly but this is what you want.
This is the consistency and uh we only use
a little bit at a time so all you need is
a small piece like this and then what you
do is you just roll it a little bit like
a snake almost and then once you have that
you take the hook ... there we go ... now
next up, we're going to take the two dips.
Never take the same dip because we need
to figure out which one the fish like.
So first we're going to do the cinnamon on the top
hook and we're going to do the sniper concentrate
on the bottom one.
Let's do that.
My grandma as well - she loved to fish.
Going to make them proud.
This is not my favorite method - I like
to catch with lures like Danie - and
we're going to give that a shot a little
bit later on as well but there we go.
In you go.
Done.
We forgot to to bring a few things to
put the rods on so we're just going to
have to take some branches here and
do what we can ... just make a plan.
Let's cast it in and see what we can catch.
Now I'm trying my granddad's method.
And I'm using Nikita's rod ... you
can see it's pink ... and you put this on.
We call it a policeman here in South Africa and
so when the fish bites you will see it move.
I'm not going to cast it in really far.
Alright.
Here you go.
All we got to do is just look at that little guy
when he starts to move up then we know it's time.
The angle.
Oh it's already biting.
So Daniel's on.
Jaques... nothing yet.
What's happening... what's
happening... what's happening.
But I don't know what it is and he's
going to Jaques's line over there.
It's quite... it's quite a nice fish.
But it plays a little bit strange... not
like a Yellowfish but you can see it.
Oh, it's taking some line.
It's an old rod.
It's Nikita's rod
as well but I think we're going to move away from
Jaques so we don't bother him here with his line.
Hey, go, yeah oh no it's a mud fish.
Taking a line again.
Man, this is awesome.
No, it's okay I'm just too hasty, but
maybe I should just wait and play a little bit.
It's a very thin line so got to be careful.
Oh, got it.
This is quite a nice mud fish.
In Africans we say Moddervis.
But let me take it out quickly here.
Alright, beautiful fish, and
that's why we call it a mud fish.
Look at the mouth there at the bottom.
It's quite strange.
It's very different from the the Yellowfish but
uh it's a nice fish and they don't get too big.
This is probably the biggest size that they
do get around 2 kg but still a beautiful fish.
So let's go put it back so
when it's ready he will go.
I don't want to push him, don't want him to die.
Come on buddy, let's go.
Thank you, there is he goes.
Ha, nice.
So the Orange River is the longest
river here in South Africa.
It is a beautiful river.
Fish on for Jaques, huh?
Yeah, hopefully this is the first Yellowfish.
How big is it Jaques? I think 20 kilos.
Now it's a little bit difficult
there in with those reeds there.
Yeah Danie, do you want to net it for him?
Unless it's a very small one which it
probably is small.
Let's see.
It's already here.
This can be the first Yellow.
It is ... it is the first Yellow.
Watch out watch out watch out ooh Danie.
You got to be careful there.
It's on the oh man are you in a hole?
And the fish is still there.
Guys... oh.
[Laughter]
Oh no, focus focus the fish is still there.
We are looking like amateurs right now.
Alright it's closing in.
There we go ... here we go.. here we go
And nice.
Jaques, first Yellow.
Ranger's also looking for it - oh yeah
- that's Tzamenkomst's hunting dog.
Looking for some fish.
I'm still stuck.
Still stuck.
I mean look at that.
This river.
Oh no, you lost your shoe.
I lost ... it's in the hole.
Oh no, alright, Jaques, still there.
Let's go check out the fish.
No it's not food it's not food
we're not going to give it to you.
Okay wow wow Jaques, wow wow it's a nice size too.
Yeah, it's beautiful let's put it back.
The dog's name is Ranger.
And Ranger just wants to eat this Yellowfish.
Let me help you.
He's going to eat it.
Come on, move it move it yeah Ranger Ranger.
Well done.
Yo, now that is a hunting dog.
The wind is picking up here guys
so we're going to go back and we're
going to try this again another day.
Ranger is still looking for the fish.
Good morning.
Man I'm still sleepy.
It is still dark out of here but
today is the big fishing day.
So I'm going to get some coffee, meet up with the
guys, and then we're going to do some fishing.
Hey can I also have some coffee?
Good morning.
Early morning here that sounds and smells good.
That's how we start a day.
Got the coffee - the most important thing -
and then I got these whole grain breakfast
biscuits that we're going to take along.
I think they should go down nicely with
the coffee.
Let's go.
Cheers.
So we get the fishing stuff.
Where's Jaques?
So we going to wake him up.
That might be a good idea.
Let's see where he is.
So the wind died down which is perfect but it
bothers me still a little bit that it's this cold.
I mean, the Yellowfish, they like warm weather.
And we had a bit of a cold front so it might
influence the biting.
We'll see.
He's still sleeping I think so as well
Jaques... nothing is happening
Jaques.
Hello?
Jaques. Jaques.
He's still sleeping.
We got to go fishing.
Oh I know.
Oh man the reflection was too much he couldn't
see that great but he was still sleeping.
We older guys, we're ready.
But the young generation these days ...
Alright, we are on the way.
We can't wait for Jaques.
We're carrying everything ourselves.
The old man ... older man ... but it is
a beautiful beautiful beautiful morning.
Plan of action ... where do you
think we should go this time?
We should go down this way to the right, yeah?
Yeah, I think that looks under the trees.
Wow, this is a beautiful spot huh.
Yeah just looks a little bit shallow.
But we'll see.
Wow this location looks perfect for today.
The wind is calm and the location oh we
can make a a fire here and it is cold oh
they've got some wood here as well Danie.
Nice.
Oh this is a beautiful spot huh.
Cool for a proper South African braai.
Yeah, I think so too.
Let's do some fishing.
2,000 years later
Jaques is finally here.
Good morning Jaques.
Are you awake now?
Finally.
The fishing is done.
We're actually going home now.
Let's get the rods in today I'm going to stick
with the method that my grandad used... my
grandma... we call this a <Afrikaans>
So let's see what we can catch.
I'm going to try the lure as well
it's a little bit cold not sure if
I'm going to get anything but if
you don't try you'll never know.
Now that was a bite.
It's just too cold.
Danie
Gave a nice pull on your rod as well,
They're just like nibbling.
Yeah, they're not really biting biting.
But you can see it I mean look at this one.
Over there we get some more action.
We just need for you to take it.
All for you.
Take it and run.
It's a bit more shallow here than I
than I would have liked it to
be.
I think I'm going to go enjoy my
coffee a little bit more... wait for
these... they're nibbling and
nibbling but not really taking it.
We might need to make a B plan here.
I tried with the lure but it's too shallow .
Yeah, this spot is a bit too quiet.
It might be the weather as well.
But I think I'm gonna change tactics here.
I think I'm going to move from here to there.
I can see some fish just jumping around.
We are slowly getting hungry so
we might go for breakfast soon.
But we don't want to go for breakfast before
we got a fish - feel like we don't deserve it.
So that one is far in.
Oh time for these cookies.
Danie how are they?
Good.
Jaques is busy getting his rod ready.
But these are quite amazing.
Healthy as well, no sugar.
This is what they look like but
I just need my coffee with this.
There we go.
I still think it's too shallow here.
And I can see the fish jumping and
playing all the way over there.
So I'm going to try with the
the lure just to give it a shot.
Maybe it's a little bit deeper there.
My legs are freezing but I gave him my all.
And it's not going to work here.
The fish are not biting at the moment.
It's too cold and it's too
shallow here where we are.
So I think we're going to go have some
breakfast because I'm hungry and then
after that we're going to try to catch bass.
There's a bass dam here and hopefully they
will be more willing to take
our lures than the Yellowfish.
Wow this is nice.
Good morning,
good morning.
Oh, more coffee.
Orange juice, yogurt, alright
we got some bread, some cheese.
Let's have a look.
Bacon, hash browns, some beans.
So good.
What's in here ooh eggs.
Ooh this is what we call <Afrikaans> in
South Africa and then we got some sauce.
Oh look at this.
Man, early in the morning.
Oh, feels so good.
This is how you start the morning huh.
Are you still cold?
Still cold ... oh my clothes are still wet.
My shoes.
Man, it's cold.
What do you got there Jaques?
Too much food.
Danie.
All the yummy goodness.
You guys are hungry, huh?
Thank you Lord Jesus for the food.
Amen.
Surprise
You guys ready?
Let's go see if we can catch some Bass.
So this gate is not working and Danie
and Jaques they're opening this gate.
But the gate is falling apart.
There we go.
It's a beautiful farm.
There's game here as well.
A lot of deer which I will
show you a little bit later.
Today is a fishing day but
tomorrow we're going hunting.
It's a beautiful little dam.
Sun is coming out - still a little bit chilly.
But you can feel the sun now.
Now these bass I'm going to try this soft plastic.
There's a lot of places where you
can get snagged - a lot of grass.
A lot of things with normal lures.
So I'm trying the soft plastic and I'm putting
the hook right in there so that we can just
reel it in and it doesn't get stuck on anything.
There's a lot of other soft
plastics that you could use.
So we brought quite a few here.
But this one is the best option.
You can see Danie's already there
and Jaques is somewhere here... oh,
he's right there behind that tree.
The best thing with bass is obstacles.
I'm going to try here and then I'm just going
to work my way around and see what we can get.
Jaques got a a nice one first.
Nice.
Jaques, it's bleeding a lot.
Oh man.
Let's.. yeah let's get it back, let's
just change location and see what we can
get.
Yeah, this is a nice spot.
Hey, Danie's got one there.
Let's go check it out.
I want to go and see if I can find another
location here while walking seeing if I can
spot some of them while I am walking to Danie
just to check out the fish that he just caught.
He said he got a small bass.
Oh, it's nice and deep here.
Nice structure.
But so much grass there.
Nice, yeah got one.
Yeah man, what lure did you use?
One of those little jelly ones.
Oh really?
It didn't even chase mine.
Oh I'll trying to follow it with the camera.
Nice.
Yeah, it nibbled nibbled
and then he took it.
Took it.
Oh, got it.
Fish on.
Yes, there we go guys.
This is a small one.
But let's see if we can catch its grandfather.
Throw back.
Alright, there it goes.
Let's get another one.
See the thing is with Bass,
you need to go and find them and hunt
them which is why I love catching Bass.
But it's also just nice you know just to take
in the moment and the surroundings around you.
I mean it is quiet - no traffic -
not music - not a lot of people.
Nothing.
Just you and nature.
We need this.
Thank you Lord Jesus.
We have to have life and
enjoy life to the fullest.
You can see it right there.
You see it moving there so I think there are two.
There's one there, one there as well.
Not sure if you will be able to see it
with the camera but I'm going to chuck
my lure there and see if I can get it.
Oh, got it.
Fish on.
I lost it... it went into all the
grass and I just, I just lost it.
I'm trying to see if I can spot some of them.
Oh there they are there they are see that big
rock just to the right of that rock.
There's one there... right there.
Oh fish on.
That's so much fun.
Oh, lost it.
Oh man, I lost it.
I think I'm going to change tactics.
Going to try a map spinner.
I'll just have to take off the
grass and stuff every now and then.
Alright let's give it a go.
Fish on.
Very small one but
at least they're chasing now.
Oh it just got off.
Oh, man, it just got off.
But at least it's working.
The map spinner... they're chasing it.
So they want some bling.
It's difficult because there's so much grass here
so you got to throw in between the deep areas.
Hey you got it.
Yeah just when I was moving away.
Woo.
Did did see it?
It was hiding there in the grass.
Yeah.
Was below.
Yeah, nice Danie.
Yeah man, just when I walked away
Oh ye of little faith.
Yeah, I'm sorry my friend.
These little ones they
need to go call Mommy and Daddy right?
There you go little guy oh and he's gone.
Man, this is a lot of fun.
Oh, there's one right over there.
Danie's got another one.
Whoo he's got a big one.
Woo this is a bit bigger one.
My goodness, not too bad.
And did you have the GoPro on?
Probably not.
I did not.
That's alright.
Let's enjoy the moment.
Well, let me get a photo.
You on showing you guys how it's done.
Yeah now this is the trick people.
Pull you know now it's a smaller fish.
Now bring it to the camera.
Oh now I got a big fish.
Oh this is a nice one.
Go and get bigger buddy.
Yeah, woo there he goes.
Like a rocket.
Yeah, well done.
Oh there's the little one
you can see it right there.
Alright threw it far in.
So let's see when we get it.
Past the little guy.
Oh... run away. Oh there oh another one.
He took it.
Wow.
Oh went behind the tree.
That's not good.
Come back, come back buddy.
Oh not in the tree.
There we go and it's out.
And it's out and it's out oh
yeah fish on... there we go.
Alright, that was a lot of fun.
Whenever you're fishing you
do need pliers like this.
It makes this so much easier.
There we go.
Alright let's put this guy back in the water.
When you do handle Bass you need to take it
here on the the bottom and just support it a
little bit here at the bottom let's put the
little guy back alright and there you go.
Oh, so much fun.
You see it right there.
Right there right there ... looking the wrong
way... come on come on yes yes yes yes oh got it.
Nice buddy.
Oh man, that's so much fun .
If you see them.
It really is huh?
Not bad.
Yeah, it's a little guy.
It's not as big as yours.
That's not too bad at all.
It's so much fun when you can see them huh.
And you see that chase there we go one two
three that's great.
Nice.
Thank you.
Let's put him back.
Alright, gone.
You got to catch it fast.
I've only got 15% on the battery, no pressure.
It's there it's underneath him.
He's going to take it.
Oh he's got it.
Oh you did you lose oh oh man it was too loose oh
no Danie, goodness always check your gear, right?
Oh Jaques is on.
Look at that one... oh you
lost it ... yeah it's off.
Oh I saw a jump.
I got this.
Oh man, I think the morning fishing is done.
We're a little bit tired
and we're going to go back.
We're going to just check out another fishing
spot for the Yellowfish quickly then we're going
to take it easy and then we're only going
to do a little bit of fishing later on.
And a barbecue that should be
quite nice around the campfire.
Jaques and Danie, they're
already here, ready to go.
And Danie got the biggest fish again.
You like the biggest fish?
Catching the biggest fish?
I'm just showing you guys how it's done.
Jaques, I didn't see with many fish today.
Only one for the day.
Oh man, but it's not my day.
I think this looks like a nice spot
oh yeah some nice rapids over here.
Oh nice.
Maybe we should get something to eat.
Get the fire while the fire is going and
see if we can catch anything and then we
eat something yeah sounds good.
It is a beautiful spot.
Cool.
While the fire is doing its thing
I think we're going to see if we
can catch anything. I'm not giving up on
this lure so I'm going to give it a try.
Danie, what are you going to do try?
A little crabby?
You going to try crabby?
Yeah, bro nice.
It should work in these rapids.
Jaques, you also crab?
Crab?
Okay, alright.
Come give this a go.
Crab might be really good.
I also brought the fly rod just in
case if the water's too shallow then
I'm going to do the fly rod.
These rocks are so slippery,
so I got to be so careful.
Man, don't want to fall here.
Jaques and Danie, they're catching over
there, but man this here is too shallow.
So I'm trying to get into some
deeper water, so right over here.
This is a nice spot here for fly fishing.
It's getting a little bit deeper so I'm going
to cast in there, reel it in, see what we
get.
Ah, no bites.
I'm going to move over there.
Alright this is a more quiet place.
Let's see if we get anything.
There no bites guys.
Nothing yet.
This is unbelievable.
Guys the sun is setting very fast.
Got only a few hours so I'm going to go back.
I'm going to try fly fishing.
Let's see if that works.
I finally found some deeper water and
there are a lot of fish jumping here.
The only problem is the sun is setting and
I got to go back and make some food and I'm
actually far away so now that I know about this
location, next time I'm going to come here.
The fire looks good.
Jaques what do you say we start the barbecue?
Sounds good.
Let's do it.
We have good food.
We're going to eat good.
We have filet, lamb sausage, garlic bread.
Look at that meat going on the fire.
This time of the day is the most beautiful.
You see the sun setting, you hear the water
in the background and the
birds.
So beautiful.
One of my favorite lamb sausages.
Where's Jaques.... Jaques loves this as well.
Jaques, what do you think about these guys?
Nice.
It's a little bit
hot but we can probably put them on right?
Because the sun is going to catch us.
Yes, do you want to put those on?
Yes, I'll put them on.
Nice and then the lamb as well going on.
Guys, how about this.
Each guy makes his own so we're
going to divide this into three.
Thank you Moroccan harisa.
Ooh this is so good for lamb.
Spicy.
Now you guys like spicy,
so for the fillet, just going to take
some thyme - some garlic for you guys.
Already at it there also take there we go Jaques.
Flame grill .. there we go... just tastes better.
Yeah it's just too hot.
So no fish but at least
we can we can have some meat.
Bread there something on the table.
At least yeah it's going to be brought this.
Do you want one?
Jaques, do you want one?
Yes please.
Oh this guy is ready.
Guys I think I'm going to
pray for us then we can eat.
Yeah yeah yeah that sounds good.
Father thank you so much for the
food and this amazing day.
We love you, we praise you.
Amen.
Man that sun.
These are so good.
Oh my goodness.
They have good taste.
It's been an amazing day so far.
Awesome sunset with good friends.
There's going to be another day
where where I'm going to come
back and I'm going to catch these Yellowfish.
We're back at the lodge now and we're going to
do Bible study together because this is a men's
weekend of the DLM team and just for some of you
who do not know the team this is Danie,
He's a team manager.
He's doing marketing - he's doing
editing - he's doing almost everything.
And then this is Jaques.
He's the head video editor,
so all the awesome videos you see that's
mostly Jaques and Danie as well and a
reason we took this break is just because we're
overworked and we took this time to come - just
do some fishing - do some hunting - just be in
nature and spend time with God, in His Word.
And to pray.
Finally we're back
Jaques and I here at the Orange River and today
we're not leaving until we catch Yellowfish and
the conditions are really good.
There hasn't been a cold front.
The weather is kind of perfect.
So I think today is the day.
So we've been walking around
the river and we don't see the
Yellowfish in the rapids so I think
it's just before spawning season.
And so we should find them
in a bit more calm water.
Oh yeah this is it.
So we've seen some of the fish here in the water
and it's awesome because it means that if we stay
here and do a bit of <Afrikaans> - my grandparents
style - then we'll definitely get something.
So Jaques said that he'll stay here and do that.
And I'm going to try the fly rod.
Swimming right there .. there
was another one moving there.
But you can see them right there.
So let's see if I can get them.
Jaque's got one.
They don't want to take the fly
but huh right in front of you.
First one for the day.
Nice.
Well done.
First one for the day.
It's so beautiful here.
So beautiful when you can see the fish .
You can see there's something swimming right here.
But this is looking more
like a barber as we call it.
There's another one right there.
Thank you so much for this beautiful day God.
Just look at Your creation.
Got on ... got it got it... nice.
Oh it's a beast.
Oh man this is fun.
This is what fly fishing is all about.
Man look at him go.
And there he goes.
The prince of the Orange River.
Oh man this is so much fun.
They're so strong because of these
currents and so it pulls my rod a lot.
Come on buddy.
Full of energy.
He does not want to come in.
I don't have my net with me so
this is going to be a challenge.
I think I'm going to bring him to the right.
I'm just going to make him a little bit tired.
And this is why we come here.
What a beautiful fish.
They're so strong because of these currents
and man, they're like small Ferraris.
Come on buddy, it's time to come in.
Nope. Okay all right all right all right
all right all right all
right all right.
Here we go.
Alright oh oh
what a beauty here we go guys what a beautiful
beautiful fish. They're made for these currents.
They're just super fast and they're
indigenous to South Africa and one of
my most favorite fish to catch.
But let's put this guy back.
So I left Jaques a little bit alone just
to go on an adventure and just to go and
be alone in nature and uh got a
nice Yellow but I'm returning to
Jaques just to see how he's doing.
Definitely the biggest one yet.
So got a big one.
Yeah no it's going good this side.
Biggest fish I've got in the river so really
yeah so I'm happy so was a PB personal best.
Definitely, yeah man that
was a was a beautiful fish.
And gave me a fight also.
Okay that's awesome.
I also got one but maybe not as big as yours.
Nice.
Listen to those sounds of the birds flying.
Wow.
Now fly fishing - you can see what
insects there are in the season.
So if you take a rock like this
- turn it around and see what we
have then - uh oh this been a bit big
- you can see - here there some worms.
Oh there there are many here.
So Jaques has been catching with dough
but I think later on we're going to come and get
some of these earthworms and see what we can get.
Oh look at this.
There's a bottle.
This is a container that we can
use to put the earthworms in.
So I came back to get Jaques
because we're changing tactics.
Jaques says it's a little bit quiet here.
Yep, and as you can see it's very shallow.
But we're going to go to those
deep waters I saw a few days ago.
And then we're going to see if we can get some big
fish with the earth worms but first Jaques we need
to go and get the earthworms.
You ready?
Out of the sun I can see CH looks like a ninja.
So I'm going to use this as a
container for our earthworms.
First rule .. never forget your knife.
So we got it.
Let's go Jaques.
So the first thing we need
is just a little bit of sand.
There we go and take out the water.
Now let's see if we can get some earthworms.
They're quite long.
Look at it so skinny.
There we go.
This is a nice one Jaques.
Yeah.
Hello there's a here o there's a lot of edge
up ...look at those there and we're just going to
get a few more and then we're going to go fishing.
We're here at the new spot.
The water is deeper and we're busy with the rods.
Jaques is busy putting the worm on so
we're going to put a worm on the bottom
one and we're going to put a dough on the top one.
And then we going to see what we're going to get.
Yours yours yours
Yes, this is so much fun.
I just threw it in and it just took it.
Yeah, yo yo there was just
another fish going there now.
This is a fighter.
It's a Yellowfish.
He's not even so big.
Jaques you're on as well.
Let's get this one in.
First, come on buddy come on, oh here we go.
Earthworms.
Just look at this ... beautiful guy.
This is so much fun.
Let's put him back.
Listen to the sound.
It's a monster with Nikita's rod.
Now it's a little bit quiet again.
Oh man, you also have something on.
Oh you have something as well Jaques.
This one is a beast.
Yeah, yes this one is...
he just took a lot of line.
He doesn't want to come in.
Come on the line is not strong.
It's so much fun Jaques.
Yep.
My goodness.
And he's got some weight on him.
He took so much line I'm busy with
him now for what 5 minutes?
Yeah it's a busy one.
Look at that rod.
This is a lot of fun.
This guy just wants to take line.
If this fish is going to be a Catfish
I'm not going to be so happy but if
it is a Yellowfish it's a monster.
It's really big and this line is
not really strong - very thin line.
Jaques, this is a monster.
Yep.
I haven't caught a fish like this in a long time.
He's strong and the current is
a bit strong as well.
So the idea would be to get
him here in the more calm water.
Ah, he's taking a line again.
How long have we been playing now, 10 minutes?
It's around 10 minutes and it's still going
strong.
Yeah.
Yo this is a big fish.
Thank you Lord Jesus.
This is so much fun.
Oh no signs of weakness yet.
I will come here again and again and again if you
guys want to come to this place I'll add all the
details in the video description for you.
It's an amazing place.
The people are amazing, it's beautiful.
There's wildlife - there's fishing - oh man
if you need some nature then just come here and
if you want monster fish, then come here as well.
Alright, I'm gaining ... I'm
gaining a little bit now.
There it goes again.
Doesn't want to come.
Jaques 15 minutes now.
Yep probably.
Yeah it's been a while.
Yeah.
Jaques I think I've got your line.
Alright show us who you are.
Ah it's running again that was close.
That was close.
Oh he's going again.
I think this might be a Catfish.
Yeah just the way he's playing this thin line.
Catfish I think ... think catfish ....oh
oh it's a catfish he's too big for the net.
For the nets so I have to get him to the side.
I was so hoping it was a Yellowfish.
It's taking but it's a lot of fun though.
Oh Jaques I forgot to mention
this is a catch and cook.
Ah so you'll need to eat catfish with me.
Not eating catfish it's a bit too slimy
for my liking.
Yo he is massive.
Alright.
Here we go.
Here we go here we go come on buddy in the
Orange River they can get very very big this
one is not even one of the biggest they can
get over 40 kilos here but you see this is
a nice nice nice nice catfish there we go
there we go there we go look at that guy.
So heavy but he put up a good
fight so so let's put him back.
Alright boy here we go .
Alright get some there he goes.
That was fun.
Nice.
Well done.
Thank you.
Now it's my turn.
Oh man that was so good
yeah now it's Jaque's turn.
I'm going to take a break.
It's heating up ... the sun is extremely
hot now .. you can see we forgot sunscreen
so Jaques put some mud on his legs just
to protect him and it's working.. yeah.
Both rods are biting but I'm just so
tired I'm going to let it do its thing
and I'm going to have some snacks.
These jalapeno pretzels are the best.
Guys this is just too much fun.
Every time we cast in they start biting and
there was a big one that took mine.
My rod got stuck.
The line broke.
Jaques just had a nice one as well that
he missed and now we just cast in
again.
Fish on ... another fish is on.
This is the Orange River.
A mudfish.
Yeah there we go .. beautiful Mudfish.
Man, we're catching all the species today.
We just need carp now.
And the carp here in the Orange River
they put up a really good fight.
But it's time to let this guy go.
When all the conditions are right
and you're at the right spot and you've
got the right bait everything just works.
Fish on with a fly rod.
So awesome to fight this
fish with a fly rod is just on another level.
So Jaques I'm going to bring it to you and then
you net it if that's okay.
Yeah I can see it.
It's a Mudfish.
I hooked it a bit on this the top part.
That's not good.
I'm bringing it to you Jaques.
There we go.
Another one.
Thank you Jaques.
It's not a big one but it's still a fighter.
Oh so good.
Freedom ... there he goes.
On fly it's fun but lure it's fun as well.
We're taking out everything today.
We're doing <Afrikaans> we're doing
lures, we're doing fly fishing.
It's just so much fun.
Oh the Mudfish, not as big as the first
one I got but still interesting huh just look at
that mouth ... kind of looks alien and he's got
this small head and there .. bump over here .
But let's.... there it goes and get bigger.
Oops so you're ready.
There he goes.
Jaques, now it's your turn.
Yeah, let's catch.
The fish are really biting.
Jaques just got another one.
As you can see another nice
Yellow that he's holding tightly.
It's strong.
Yeah.
And the river just came up.
We were actually there on that island and
then the river just came up and we had to retreat
to this little spot over here but this is where
we're going to continue fishing Jaques.
Well done.
Thank you.
Fish on.
Another one Jaques.
It doesn't get old.
This is so much fun.
I can just stand here and do this the whole day.
Nikita is going to be so proud,
catching so many fish with her with rod.
Taking line oh no ... mudfish mudfish
why am I catching so many mudfish.
So never try to touch the fish just like this with
your dry hands it's not good make it wet a little
bit then you touch it they have this protective
layer that's what it feels so disgusting for a
lot of people - for especially women - because
like you but it actually protects them so when
you touch it with your dry hands the fish
is not protected from diseases and things.
So this is what you have to do.
There he goes.
We had an amazing time here at the
Orange River but it's time to go
because the sun is beating us and we are burning.
We would have liked to stay
longer but, we gotta head on home.